[Music]
good afternoon everyone my name is Isaac
Kolbert and I'm associate dean of the
Graduate School here at MIT on behalf of
MIT and the MLK memorial celebration
committee let me welcome all of you to
this 18th annual celebration of the life
and work of a great American leader dr.
Martin Luther King jr. let me also thank
you for braving the frigid weather to be
with us today
it seems that on most occasions we have
weather like this and it's nice to see
that in spite of it people choose to
attend the ceremony the theme for this
year's observance as well as for the 3rd
annual conference on youth is what
messages help youth realize their dreams
media music models and microchips in
these yearly celebrations we continue
our focus on youth not only to help
young people better understand the
significance of dr. King's life and
legacy and how it affects their lives
today but also to stimulate our
youngsters into developing their own
visions and their own dreams and making
them a reality before we begin our
program today I would like to recognize
a number of people who have provided
support for this year's celebration but
whose names did not appear in the
program serving as our ushers here in
Kresge today Derrick Forbes van der
Merriman Christology owns Camille
Anderson Porsha Parkinson and Fritz
Francis in the stirring entertainment in
Lobby 7 this month this afternoon was
provided by Aida in tan boo Ruben
Morphin nancy Martin and juror Priya Lo
and a special thanks today to mrs.
Rebecca vest for a help with this
morning's breakfast in honor of our
keynote speaker
I'd like to draw your attention in the
program to a number of things that that
you really should not miss and be aware
of excuse me this weekend is the
conference on youth which is sponsored
by the community Fellows Program it's a
theme of media music microchips and
models provides some important input to
today to our youth we hope you'll be
able to attend it participants are asked
to make a $5 donation to help defray the
cost of this conference but if you're
not able to do that no one will be
turned away I urge you to attend this
important conference Saturday evening
here in this auditorium there will be a
marvelous performance by Semenya McCourt
and her associates entitled journey into
a dream a musical tribute to Martin
Luther King jr. and if you have not seen
miss McCord and her associates perform I
think you're in for a real treat and I
urge you to come to that this evening
beginning at 5 o'clock pardon me this
evening beginning at 5 o'clock there
will be a an important exhibit getting
underway by a black artist valerie may
not that exhibit is entitled no
apartheid anywhere and it is one of the
first exhibits of this size and scope by
a black artist at MIT she does marvelous
work I think all of you should visit it
it is in the Compton gallery in building
10 just through the main lobby and into
into the second rotunda she has her
opening at five o'clock and the her
exhibit will continue through most of
the following week finally I'd like to
invite all of you to attend the lecture
entitled getting smart by this year's
Martin
luther king jr scholar who is dr.
geoffrey howard of the efficacy
institute that will be again on tuesday
january 21st at 3 p.m. in building two
room 105 dr. howard has worked for many
years on issues of educating our youth
and he has some important things to say
not only to the MIT community but to the
broader communities of cambridge in
boston i urge you to be there and now
long with our program we will begin our
program this morning with an invocation
leading us in a prayer that were both
stimulators and warmest will be the
reverend cassandra brown who was
associate minister of the Western Avenue
Baptist Church here in Cambridge
Reverend brown
[Applause]
would you stand with me for the
invocation please father it's truly a
privilege and an honor to be here Lord
we see from the gathering that we've
come a long way we stand and sit in the
midst of an auditorium Lord of one of
the best-known universities in the
nation possibly in the world for
engineering and technology we sit Lord
God together people of color all races
all mixtures none fearing one another
Lord truly we've come a long way father
we come today to commemorate and
celebrate the life of one of your lights
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. Lord
whose light was quenched because the
darkness did not understand it and could
not comprehend it but today Lord God we
gather stating that we comprehend it
that we understand it and indeed we
desire to keep that flame going a little
bit longer Lord in the words of a negro
slave we're not where we used to be
we're not where we're going to be we're
not as far as we need to be Lord but we
praise you because we're not what we
used to be we've changed Lord and it's
because of the life of dr. King now Lord
we commit ourselves anew in your service
Lord understanding that you have given
equity to all people that we were all
created in your image Lord therefore
each life is valuable we thank you for
the message that he taught and that he
lived and we thank you Lord that today
we stand together unified working to
bring about his goal working to see his
vision and his dream realized we thank
you for him to God we thank you for all
those who were assembled and ask Lord
that you bless our efforts today that
you help us to continue on in the dream
and to one day make that dream a lasting
and a living reality father we said of
the decade Lord where we're entering the
21st century father King has long since
died but the dream lives on yet not
accomplished we ask Lord for the vision
for the strength and for the drive to
accomplish the dream today we thank you
Lord again for this
opportunity we thank you Lord for your
servant and we pray for the ability to
work continuously as your servants not
fearing any man
but working together Lord understanding
that once we are united we will not fall
once we are united we will not be
divided by any foe and understanding
that perfect love casts out all fear
teach us to love one another Lord teach
us to live as your servant lived and not
only to remember him but to enact his
goals and his visions to make those real
again in our lives understanding that as
long as we chase after his vision he
really will never die again o God we
come before you saying thank you and
praising you for your greatness and your
goodness and for your servant dr. King
and your son's name we pray amen now
we'll join together and sing what has
become the Negro national anthem lift
every voice and sing it's found on the
back of your programs will sing all
three verses
[Music]
[Applause]
please take your seats I don't know
about you but I'm inspired for each
year's program we invite young people
from MIT and from the surrounding
community to share with us their
perspectives on the significance of dr.
King and his work this year we were very
pleased to have with us from the
Cambridge Rindge and Latin School mr.
Augustine
Anya Goro in this teeny Ola a Diwali and
from MIT
miss De Vita Johnson and mr. Marcus
Allen Gilbert mr. Anya Garo and miss our
Wally will give their presentations
together followed by a Miss Johnson and
mr. Gilbert
- president vest to our esteemed speaker
to the other members of today's program
and to you our audience we bid you a
fond good afternoon it is indeed a
privilege and an honor to come before
you along with my good friend and fellow
upper bound student - new Ola to
commemorate the life of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. given the theme of this
year's program media music models and
microchips and their role in the
realization of dreams
Tina Waller and I will explore the dream
of Martin Luther King jr. as healer of
community and country today marks a
celebration of what would have been the
63rd birthday of Martin Luther King jr.
and on this day we should give pause for
reflection when I think about the
relatively brief life on Martin Luther
King jr. I am filled with feelings of
both joy and sadness joy because he
lived and threw his life's work he made
our country confront his hostility
prejudice ignorance and fear and thereby
challenged us to work together to make
America truly the land of freedom
justice equality opportunity and
brotherhood and sadness because a
senseless and cowardly act of violence
cut short his life and thereby deprived
my generation of the opportunity to
person experience all that is and was
Martin Luther King jr. dr. King should
be an inspiration to us every day for
thanks to as many contributions we are
free to dream we can dream over time
when all things negative in this country
will be eliminated we can dream up times
of great prosperity in our community and
we can dream about the many personal and
professional successes we will achieve
we can dream about these things and more
however today we must ask ourselves how
will we get there from here
25 years ago in his last address to the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
dr. King addressed the same question
when he said now in order to answer the
question where do we go from here we
must first honestly recognize where we
are now when the Constitution was
written a strange formula to determine
taxes and representation to clear that
the Negro was 60% of a person today
another curious formula seems to declare
that he is 50% of a person of the good
things in life the Negro has
approximately one-half those of whites
of the bad things of life he has twice
those of whites
thus half of all Negroes live in
substandard housing and Negroes have
half the income of whites when we view
the negative experiences of life the
Negro has a double share there are twice
as many unemployed the rate of infant
mortality among Negroes has doubled that
of whites and there are twice as many
Negroes dying in war as whites in
proportion to their size of the
population in other spheres the figures
are equally alarming in elementary
schools Negroes like 1 2 3 years behind
white and their segregated schools
received substantially less money per
student than the white school's 120th as
many Negroes as whites attend college of
employed Negroes 75% hold menial jobs
while I was not born the time dr. King
made this address
I believe his assessment of the day's
problems would be fairly accurate if
applied today
so where do we go from here if we return
to that same Southern Christian
Leadership Conference address dr. King
provided prescription for an ailing
black community in America when he said
first you must massively assert our
dignity and worth you must stand up a
missile system that still oppresses us
and developed an unassailable and
majestic sense of values we must no
longer be ashamed of being black
another basic challenge is discover how
to organize our strength in terms of
economic and political power indeed one
of the great problems that the Negro
faces is the lack of power stripped of
the right to make decisions concerning
his life and destiny the Negro has been
subjected to the authoritarian and
sometimes whimsical decisions of the
white power structure the plantation and
ghetto were created by those who had
power both to confine those who had no
power and to perpetuate their
powerlessness the problem of
transforming the ghetto therefore as a
problem of power confrontation of the
forces of power demanding change and the
forces of power dedicated to the
preserving of the status quo there is
nothing wrong with power if power is
used correctly one of the great problems
of history is that the concepts of love
and power have usually been contrasted
as opposites polar opposites so that
love is identified with a resignation of
power and power with a denial of love
now forgot to get this thing right what
is needed is a realization that power
without love is reckless and abusive and
in love without power is sentimental and
anemic power at its best is love
implementing the demands of justice and
justice at its best is power correcting
everything that's danced against love
what has happened is that we have had it
wrong and confused in our own country
and this has led Negro Americans in the
past to seek their goals to power devoid
of love and conscience this is leading a
few extremists today to advocate for
Negroes the same destructive and
conscienceless power that they have just
the abhorred and lights it is precisely
this collision of immoral power with
powerless morality which constitutes the
major crisis of our times
we must develop a program that would
drive the nation to a guaranteed annual
income we've come a long way in our
understanding of human motivation and of
the blind operation of our economic
system now we realize that the
dislocations in the market operations of
our economy and the prevalence of
discrimination thrust people into a
darkness and bind them in constant or
frequent unemployment against their will
we also know that no matter how the
economy develops and experience it does
not eliminate our poverty the problem
indicates that emphasis must be twofold
we must create full employment or we
must create incomes our country can do
this if our nation can spend thirty five
billion dollars a year to fight an
unjust
evil war in Vietnam and 20 billion
dollars to put a man on the moon it can
spend billions of dollars to put God's
children on their own two feet right
here on earth
now let me say briefly that we must
reaffirm our commitment to non-violence
the futility of violence in the struggle
for racial justice has been tragically
etched in other recent Negro riots at
best the riots have produced a little
additional anti-poverty money and a few
sprinklers to cool the children of the
ghettos nowhere have the rights when any
concrete improvements such as how to
organize protest demonstrations no
internal revolution has ever succeeded
in overthrowing government by violence
unless the government had already lost
the allegiance and effective control of
its armed forces anyone in his right
mind note that this will not happen in
the United States furthermore few of any
violent revolutions have been successful
unless the violent minority have a
sympathy and support of the non-existent
majority it is perfectly clear that a
violent revolution on the part of
American blacks would find no sympathy
and support from whites and very little
for the majority of Negroes themselves
and so I say to you that I still stand
by non-violence and the other thing is
that I am concerned about a better world
I'm concerned about justice I'm
concerned about Brotherhood I'm
concerned about truth and when one is
concerned about these he can never
advocate violence for through violence
he may murder a murderer but you can't
murder murder through volunteer may
murder a liar but you can't establish
the truth through violence you may
murder a hater but you can't murder hate
darkness cannot put out darkness only
light can do that and I say to you that
I have also decided to stick to love I
want to say to you as I move to my
conclusion as we talk about where we go
from here
that we honestly face the fact that the
mover must address itself to the
question of restructuring the whole of
American society there are 40 million
poor people here and one day you must
ask the question why are there 40
million poor people in America and when
you ask that question you're raising
questions about the economic system
about a broader distribution of wealth
and I'm simply saying that more and more
we've got to begin to ask questions
above the whole society
when I'm saying to you is that communism
forget that life is individual
capitalism forgets that life is social
and the kingdom of brotherhood is found
neither and the thesis of communism nor
the antithesis of capitalism but in our
highest synthesis it is found in a
higher synthesis that combines the
truths of both
now when I say question the whole
society it means ultimately coming to
see that the problem of racism the
problem of economic exploitation and the
problem of war are all tied together so
I conclude by saying that we have a task
and let's go up with a divine
dissatisfaction let us be dissatisfied
until America will no longer have a high
blood pressure of creeds and an anemia
of deeds let us be dissatisfied until
the tragic walls that separate the outer
city of wealth and the comfort from the
inner city of poverty and despair shall
be crushed by the battering rams of the
forces of justice let us be dissatisfied
until those that live on the outskirts
of hope are brought into the metropolis
of daily security let us be dissatisfied
until integration is not seen as a
problem but as an opportunity to
participate in the beauty of diversity
let us be dissatisfied until men and
women however black they may be will be
judged on the basis of the content of
their character and not on the basis of
the color of their skin let us be
dissatisfied and Men will recognize that
out of one blood God made all men to
dwell upon the face of the earth let us
be the satisfied let us be the satisfied
until that day when nobody would shout
white power when nobody would shout
black power but everybody will talk
about God's power and human power in
closing when one considers dr. King's
address or 25 years ago his words were
prophetic 10 and they still represent a
plausible course of action if we would
only dare a dream on behalf of Tina wall
and myself we thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon dr. Martin Luther King
jr. was a man dedicated to the life of
God through his divine faith and eternal
hope not only did he'd never lose sight
of his dream
he gave us life to make it come true
throughout my life I have experienced
different types of struggles whether it
be a confrontation with my mirror image
a fight between good and evil
the betrayal of a close friend or the
loss of a loved one it's very hard to
see the light with its when it seems
that darkness rules the world it's very
hard to swim to the top if an anchor is
pulling you down it's difficult to see
where you're going if a blindfold is
tied around your eyes it's almost
impossible to jump off a building and
survive and it's hard to live your dream
I mean you want it to be your worst
nightmare dr. Martin Luther King jr.
educated many but most importantly to me
he inspired us to have the faith that we
are doing the right thing and to have
hope that our dreams will become real
because of dr. Martin Luther King
through all of my past and future
difficulties I would never lose sight of
my dreams but I would make them happen
you have all heard the phrase dr. King
of dr. King if a man hasn't found
something worth dying for he isn't fit
to live I've witnessed this very
statement if I only see value by
materialistic measures if I only give X
if I only give expecting a return if I
only see success through selfish eyes
then the changes I've made it would be
the same as if I haven't been born at
all thank you
[Applause]
although delivered in 1963 Martin Luther
King's I have a dream speech means the
past the present and the future to me it
means the past because it symbolizes the
plight of the african-american and
recognizes the burning desire of those
oppressed to brief free it recognizes
the violent struggle that blacks have
faced over the years even in the darkest
hour the sweltering summer of Negroes
legitimate discontent as King called it
we remained undaunted I see the fervor
of my black ancestors through my parents
when a recording of this famous speech
is played on television my parents focus
on the screen with a solemn
concentration and pride as they become
mindful of their own trials and
tribulations in their path to fulfill
the dream this speech means the present
because recognizing the present means
recognizing that the dream is not yet
reality ethnic violets still persist and
as King says we cannot be satisfied as
long as the Negro's basic mobility is
from a smaller ghetto to a larger one
recognizing the speech also means
recognizing responsibility my
responsibility our responsibility in
each in his speech Martin Luther King
says now is the time well now is still
the time and now is our time I as a
black man have the responsibility to
combat the ills of our society and
uphold the legacy of my people
recognizing the dream also means looking
forward toward the future the catalyst
that makes dreams become reality is time
as Martin Luther King States 1963 is not
an end but a beginning we must remember
that the dream is a beginning and we
must work toward the end we must also
realize that at times we are shrinking
away as a nation
instead of progressing towards our
American dream for me the dream means
working today towards a better tomorrow
while reflecting on the contributions of
our mothers and fathers
remember to keep dreaming thank you
[Applause]
certainly listening to the hearing the
eloquence and the conviction of young
people like these should really help us
all to realize that maybe just maybe yet
this country will be left in some good
hands let's hope so join me again in a
round of applause
it is now my honor and pleasure to
introduce to you the president of MIT
dr. charles invest who will introduce
our keynote speaker for the day
[Applause]
thank you very much hike I'm pleased to
add my welcome to mi t--'s 18th annual
celebration of the life and work
ideals of dr. Martin Luther King jr. the
theme of this year's observance has to
do with the messages messages that this
society sends its young people and of
the influence those messages have on the
development of their dreams messages are
conveyed in many ways through popular
culture through the content of our
curricula and the conduct of our classes
through the laws that we pass and the
leaders we elect through the symbolic
events that we choose to celebrate this
year 1992 is remarkable for the several
major anniversaries that our society is
marking it is the 500th anniversary of
Columbus's voyage to this hemisphere a
voyage of discovery to be sure but
discovery of a world and a people which
were here long before 1492 it is the
300th anniversary of the Salem witch
trials a period that reminds us all of
the dangers of ignorance and intolerance
we have just celebrated the 200th
anniversary of the Bill of Rights one of
the most important social contracts in
history however we continue to struggle
to ensure that all citizens truly
receive the full benefits of this great
contract and it has been just
sixty-three years from the day that dr.
Martin Luther King jr. was born and
almost a quarter of a century since he
died the events that we choose to
commemorate are important they send
powerful messages about the culture and
values of our society just as the
actions of our institutions do today I
would like to raise some concerns about
the messages at this country this
institution conveyed to our young people
sometimes
purposefully sometimes inadvertently
first I am concerned about the message
contained in the government ruling that
federal funds cannot be used for thright
lis to support scholarship and
fellowship programs for minority
students and that colleges and
universities may not even be able to
solicit funds for such programs from
private sources I believe that this
country should be willing and able to
make an investment in the years of
education and training particularly at
the graduate level that are necessary to
make the full range of educational and
career options open and available to
people of color
second I am concerned about the message
that is sent to our students all of our
students when they do not see the
changing face of America reflected in
our faculty at MIT we have demonstrated
leadership in enrolling undergraduates
with a diversity of ethnic and racial
backgrounds but one of the most pressing
challenges is to encourage more students
particularly students of color to pursue
Graduate Studies and academic careers
this is not easy to do when there's so
few role models for them to observe and
follow third I am concerned about the
message that is sent to our minority
staff members when they see that the
senior administrators are still
overwhelmingly white
I've been asked quite frankly whether
there's a glass ceiling for minority
administrative staff at MIT
we certainly do not intend for there to
be one but we clearly have to do much
more to provoke the career to promote
the career development of all of our
administrators at the Institute if we
are to counter these messages we need to
state clearly in words and more
importantly in actions what it is we
really want this institution to be well
what can I report after one year in
office first with regard to financial
aid programs for minority students we
are working through the various national
higher education consortium
distend to send strong and unified
message scholarship program
in this country need to be designed to
encourage full and open educational
access to students of every race beyond
that MIT is engaged in litigation with
the Department of Justice over the way
in which we administer our financial aid
programs we have admitted our students
on the basis of academic merit and we
provide financial aid based solely on
the students economic need we have met
together with other universities to make
sure for those students admitted to more
than one of our institutions that we
have had the same understanding of that
student's financial circumstances then
we awarded financial aid on the basis of
the family's ability to pay not on their
academic credentials not on their
athletic skill we think this is the
right thing and it is an approach that
serves our neediest students many of
whom unfortunately are students of color
on the faculty side we have put in place
new programs to recruit minority faculty
and women faculty the Provost mark
Righton has asked each department to
designate a faculty member who has the
responsibility to develop lists of
possible candidates for faculty
positions and they have done so in
addition we have provided special
funding to bring visiting scholars and
lecturers to campus we will provide
departments with additional resources
and scholars allowances to help support
new minority or women faculty members
and when a department finds such a
candidate for a faculty position but
does not have a specific opening we will
provide funding for that position this
is a new program just begun this fall
but I have every hope that in the long
run it will make a difference because
the difference is needed I have to tell
you that I am unhappy with the lack of
progress that we have made on this front
this year but I am encouraged by the
response of the departments to these new
efforts and I hope that I will have a
much brighter message to report to you
next year at this time
with regard to minority administrators
last fall I appointed a working group to
develop specific strategies for
increasing the number of minority
administrators at senior levels in
particular at the Institute and for
enhancing their career growth here I
know that this group is hard at work and
I expect to receive their
recommendations in the coming month or
two and what about the students one of
our great hopes for the future indeed
our best hope rests as you have seen
this morning with our students we need
to reach out to bring talented students
here and to encourage them in the
pursuit of Graduate Studies and academic
careers this is what is going to lead to
full participation by all of our
citizens in this increasingly technology
base of society in this regard I think
our efforts to improve the quality of
education particularly Science and
Mathematics education in our primary and
secondary schools will make a difference
in the number of minority students who
will be prepared for education at places
like MIT and I am very pleased with the
new efforts on behalf of the Graduate
School to encourage more
african-americans and Hispanics to come
to Cambridge to come to MIT to pursue
their graduate studies these are a few
of the things that we have launched in
the past year but I'm quick to add we
have not seen a real payoff yet but I am
encouraged by a new sense of commitment
of working together to develop ideas and
programs that will make a real
difference for the issue in my view is
not one of so-called mainstream MIT
allowing or permitting different kinds
of people to come here it is not that
rather it is one of becoming a different
kind of place one that draws on the full
range of talents and ideas of all of the
members of its community to do this we
need to work together for common goals
with your help I am confident that we
can make a difference and that we will
thank you very much
it is now my very great pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker
Margaret Burnham is a civil rights
attorney and lecturer and political
science we are fortunate to have here at
MIT in the early 1970s she was staff
attorney to the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense Fund where she worked on school
desegregation and student rights causes
in the south she first came to national
public prominence in 1972 when she
served as the defense counsel to the
civil rights advocate activist Angela
Davis in 1977 she became the first
African American woman to serve as a
judge in Massachusetts when she was
appointed by then Governor Michael
Dukakis to serve as a Boston municipal
judge a municipal court judge in this
capacity she paid special attention to
the representation of indigent
defendants and the treatment of women by
our courts she served on the bench for
six years before resigning the life
tenured position to become director of
the National Conference of black lawyers
judge Burnham is now a partner in the
first african-american woman law firm in
New England
Burnham Hynes and dill day she is chair
of the Massachusetts Committee for
Public Counsel services the state agency
responsible for the defense of indigent
clients and she is also chair of the
fund for free South Africa as a lecturer
in political science at MIT her teaching
and research interests are in the areas
of constitutional criminal civil rights
and discrimination law as our keynote
speaker this afternoon she will be
speaking to us about dr. Martin Luther
King jr. his times our times judge
Burnham
good afternoon Thank You president vest
for that warm welcome and thank you
city year for coming out and forth today
[Music]
[Applause]
the Upward Bound program members of the
community fellows program thank you for
inviting me to participate in what has
been a long tradition here of trying to
build community on Martin Luther King's
birthday as Justin and teen Yola so well
said Martin Luther King would have been
but 63 years old on January 15 1992 if
he had not been struck down by a bullet
in Memphis 63 the age of our neighbors
our colleagues our fathers our mothers
our teachers our mentors and our leaders
not an old man our contemporary it's
perhaps this nearness that makes dr.
King's birthday celebration so unique
and so different from the other national
days of Memorial that we as a country
commemorate Martin is still very much
flesh and blood to us bone and fiber
tears and sweat he has only just left us
his deep baritone voice as we heard it
as we came in to this hall still an echo
in our ears much like a room freshly
vacated even if only through the pages
of our daily newspapers many of us in
this Hall knew Martin Luther King some
of us who are here walked down the same
roads he walked down others who are here
may have scorned his methods as too
conciliatory even as we were uplifted by
his spirituality and his perseverance
others of us also here today may have
raised our eyebrows at strokes that
seemed too bold and too
risky for a country only just getting
accustomed to the end of Jim Crow most
of us who are here were alive on April
4th 1968 and shuddered and then moaned
together as a country and as Martin
faltered and then collapsed on the
Lorraine hotel balcony so fresh so raw
and haunting is the memory of Martin's
death his blood spilling out over his
colleagues Ralph Abernathy and Andrew
Young and james Bevel that the birthday
we mark every January seems as much
funereal as it does celebrit Orry in a
sense then this holiday when we come
together to honor Martin we also come
together to walk back into our own lives
as much as to reflect on Martin King's
short but rich sojourn with us it is as
De Vita and Marcus have told us an
annual journey in quest of the answers
to two interlocking questions the
meaning of his life and time and its
bearing on our own lives today
thus January 15th has never been a
static memorial to a dead and fossilized
hero nor can we permit the story of dr.
King and the movement he represents to
be co-opted and diluted commercialized
and canonized under the undifferentiated
spotlight of a national holiday it is
still our movement and it is we who must
define it it is far too soon to wrap up
our Martin Luther King celebrations in
rigid rituals commemorating an
untouchable icon of a bygone era first
of all because the history we
commemorate today is the story of what
happened just yesterday and the details
yet to be fully unfolded and secondly
because dr. King's vision what
schoolchildren everywhere have been
taught to call the king dream was meant
to be a yardstick against which we might
measure our progress as a people and as
a nation and that assess assessing and
taking stock of that we do today suggest
a fluid process a process of
interpreting the events of the past in
the context of today's reality surely
the realities of our lives have vastly
changed since the 1960s but in ways that
seem to render the vision of the
movement a distant Mirage even while we
as a people take on new shape and form
invisibility on the American landscape
we African Americans are at the same
time both more empowered and more
impoverished now than we were then and
surely we must ask about that
contradiction let me return to the first
question what was the movement of which
dr. King was a part what was his role in
that movement how did he come into the
leadership of that movement would that
movement have taken a different shape
had he not been there at all or had he
not been assassinated when he was with
the picture of the movement have been
altered if King had not been so much a
part of that picture what were the
unique dimensions of the relationship
between this individual of powerful and
universal voice himself a very reluctant
leader and a movement that sought to
lift up those who had been voiceless and
whom few white persons wished to hear
person is very unlike the articulate and
dynamic Martin Luther King it is this
history that scholars are now piecing
together beginning to emerge as the
density and complexity of a grassroots
movement across the South that laid the
groundwork for the now-famous campaigns
in which dr. King played so instrumental
a role Robert Moses likens this movement
to a huge ocean its waves peaking and
then subsiding over and over again the
peaks were high moments when the
organizing efforts of scores of years
would come to fruition Montgomery
Alabama was such a peak and only now
1992 are we beginning to uncover the
layers of Rosa Parks dance in of dr.
King's emergence on to the national
scene in Montgomery through the stories
of women like Joanne Robinson a longtime
leader of the Women's Political Council
in Montgomery we've begun to learn about
the predecessor movements to the
Montgomery Improvement Association the
Women's Political Council had been
protesting segregated buses for several
years before the arrest of Rosa Parks
Rosa Parks did not just arise one
morning and decide to make history
rather she was part of a long movement
protesting segregation on the school
buses we also know now that we're
getting we've gotten and are telling our
schoolchildren a distorted version of
exactly what the demands were in
Montgomery in respect to desegregation
of the school buses at that time the
practice in Montgomery Alabama where 70%
of the people who rode those buses were
black was that white filled up all the
seats until we reached the middle point
of the bus and then blacks filled up all
the seats and if more whites got on the
bus then those blacks who were seated
from the rear to the middle would have
to get up and give up their seats
I always was under the view that the
Montgomery movement claims that the
demand of the Montgomery movement was to
end segregation in its entirety on the
school buses on the excuse me on the
buses in Montgomery but no was a much
more modest demand what those in
Montgomery were asking for was an end to
the practice whereby blacks had to yield
their seats if whites overflowed into
their half of the bus what was at what
was being asked for simply was equal
space on the bus not an end to the
blacks in the back and whites in the
front practice and it was that very
modest request which which was refused
and denied in which way it led to 13
months of protest and walking and of
writing in neighbors cars and of
carpooling in Montgomery Alabama that
was a wave on the ocean the organization
of the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee snick by Ella Baker was a wave
on that ocean as was the entire
Mississippi movement a movement whose
dimensions we are only now beginning to
define for ourselves a movement so
painfully misshapen and misrepresented
in the public imagination by the film
Mississippi Burning some years ago
charismatic leaders Martin yes but also
Bob Moses himself Fannie Lou Hamer and
in another context Malcolm X were all
peaks and waves on that ocean surely dr.
King saw how deep that ocean was and how
wide it stretched for he prophesied
repeatedly that although he might not
see that movement to its end its work
with nonetheless go on in his last days
and
she gave the night before he died he
told us I don't know what will happen
now we've got some difficult days ahead
but it really doesn't matter with me now
because I've been to the mountaintop and
I don't mind like anybody I'd like to
live a long life longevity has its place
but I'm not concerned with that now I
just want to do God's will and he's
allowed me to go up to the mountain and
I've looked over and I've seen the
promised land and I may not get there
with you but I want you to know tonight
that we we as a people will get to the
promised land and so I'm happy tonight
I'm not worried about anything I'm not
fearing any man
mine eyes have seen the glory of the
coming of the Lord he knew he knew
somehow that he would not be with us but
that the ocean would keep roaring on one
cannot comprehend dr. King without
filling out the pages of the movements
history book and if that movement was in
ocean we have yet to learn what all the
forces were that caused it to dry up
similarly as time begins to rest more
comfortably on our collective memories
of dr. King and as we draw back from the
shock of his martyrdom we will be able
to look more accurately at the impact of
his political philosophy on the movement
and its legacy questions abound for
venturesome scholars and activists and
organizers here if non-violence was a
way of life for dr. King was it ever
more than a momentary strategy and
tactic for the masses who made up the
movement could any differences be drawn
between the adherence to non-violence
among those in the south and movement
activists in the new urban north and if
there were differences what were the
moral and really
antecedents of these differing
approaches to our struggle where if at
all can the remnants of dr. King's
nonviolent social action be found in
today's political life these are
questions to which we have yet to
uncover the answers with time to perhaps
the official version of dr. King's
murder will warrant closer scrutiny just
as Oliver Stone's JFK has served to
focus a critical public lens upon the
official JFK assassination story it was
not until almost ten years ago - excuse
me ten years after dr. King was killed
that the American public learned the
disgusting truth about the protracted
campaign launched against dr. King by
the FBI his hotel rooms bugged his FCA
SCLC staff infiltrated poison letters
sent to him constant visual surveillance
telephone threats as dr. King himself
described it the FBI was much like the
KKK quote out to break me unquote
we now know - that FBI files documented
no fewer than 50 threats against dr.
King's life finally the full details of
the days leading up to dr. King's
assassination in Memphis have been
stingy ly parsed out bit by bit and it
cannot yet be said that we have the
whole picture we know for example that
among dr. King's associates in Memphis
was an FBI informant that police plants
had infiltrated the Memphis invaders a
militant group of young men who had
precipitated a violent clash with the
police at a March led by dr. King days
before he died and we know also that a
young black man who observed the the
shooting of dr. clean King and who
claimed at the time of dr. King shooting
that he was a man
the invaders ultimately we've discovered
was in fact a member
undercover agent excuse me an undercover
member of the Memphis Police Department
one of the few people who observed the
events from that balcony at the Lorraine
hotel we also know that dr. King deeply
despaired of the violence that had
broken out in Memphis during the protest
demonstration he held there late in
march violence that we now know but at
the time he did not know have been
inspired by police infiltrators he felt
his message of non-violence was losing
his appeal and we know from an FBI
telephone bug of his conversation with a
friend that he said all I'm saying is
that Roy and I'm quoting from dr. King
all I'm saying is that Roy Wilkins and
others the Negroes who are influenced by
what they read in the newspapers they
will say Martin Luther King is dead he's
finished his non-violence is nothing no
one is listening to it he was deeply
troubled and despaired and in despair by
what had occurred and indeed after that
march in Memphis the New York Times
called the Memphis violence which had
led to the death of a young demonstrator
quote unquote a powerful embarrassment
to dr. King and the Times recommended
that dr. King call off his Poor People's
Campaign which he was then in the midst
of organizing thus the Memphis violence
which had been generated by the police
had left dr. King personally demoralized
and politically at sea surely as far as
jf J Edgar Hoover was concerned nothing
could have pleased him more it was Jay
Edgar who you will remember had widely
proclaimed dr. King as public enemy
number one for the Martin Luther King of
was politically speaking a far more
complex and threatening man than the
leader of the Montgomery and Birmingham
and Albany campaigns having tried
virtually in vain to budge the race and
class structures of Chicago with his
operation breadbasket dr. King was now
articulating a far broader program a
year to the date prior to his murder on
April 4th of 1967 and his famous
Riverside Church address he had uncatted
Oracle II condemned the Vietnam War
denouncing the United States as the
quote greatest purveyor of violence in
the world today he laid a woman black
folk that quote we can't solve our
problems now until there's a radical
redistribution of economic and political
power in America and he urged a
recognition of the reality that the
evils of racism economic exploitation
and militarism are all tied together and
you really can't get rid of one without
getting rid of the other while today's
ear might perhaps not cringe at these
stark truisms dr. King paid a high price
for his embrace of a more radical
perspective especially in regard to the
Vietnam War public opinion polls at the
time showed that 73% of Americans
disagreed with his opposition to the
Vietnam War that 60% believed his
position on the war would hurt the Civil
Rights agenda and blacks were not
altogether enthusiastic about his his
his move on to what they considered to
be foreign political turf either only 25
percent of black respondents agreed with
dr. King's position on the war 48
percent thought he was wrong at the same
time as his popularity was declining
because of his alliance with the peace
movement his anti-war positions forces
farm
radical than dr. King the Black Panther
Party for example we're emerging out of
the rubble of the 1965 Watts explosion
as a challenge on his left
thus dr. King was poised on shifting
political ground reaching out to embrace
new coalition's and causes while holding
on to the tenets of non-violence in the
face of urban rebellions in a militant
Black Power movement had he been able to
had he been able to enhance his
leadership role in these circumstances
with his message of economic equality
dr. King would surely have been an even
more threatening force to deal with it
was the more mature Martin the more
seasoned Martin the Martin who believed
as he put it that the whole structure of
American life must be changed and not
the Martin who dreamed of black and
white school children ago attending
class together it was that Martin who
was killed in 1968 and if he is to be
transformed into a national icon then it
is our place to not to permit that to
happen by cutting off the legs on which
dr. King finally stood furthermore
furthermore we may yet conclude that his
death was not the result of a government
conspiracy but nevertheless it seems
manifest that certain elements of the
government were happy to see him go when
he did in light of this political
reality the loosen is still dangling
from the several investigations into the
King assassination demand honest
examination and resolution the two
questions to explore at a King
commemoration are closely related I
suggested when we began and as did my
fellow speakers from this podium first
what is our contemporary understanding
of dr. King in his world and second how
does the vision of the movement bear on
our own circumstances we cast an eye
back and then wearing the eyes of dr.
King and of the movement of the day of
that day we look around at ourselves and
assess our own reality if it
accomplished little else the movement
threw off America's blinders and
rendered visible
Ralph Ellison's man the Negro was no
longer a silent sufferer she had a voice
and a vision she could be seen and heard
Herbert Lee Chaney Goodman and Schwerner
MZ Moore Medgar Evers Malcolm X Martin
what would they see today what happened
after they were all killed for believing
that black folk had a right to be seen
surely they would see that the civil
rights agenda that they had so carefully
constructed had indeed been successfully
enshrined in the law books the Civil
Rights Act the Voting Rights Act the
public accommodations Act but could we
blame their curiosity nay more likely
their anger when they discovered that
the written word compromised though it
had been by a hostile Supreme Court that
that were it bolide a woeful reality
that we African Americans remain twice
as unemployed as whites that we only
earn 56 dollars for every $100 that
whites earn that a white who has a high
school degree earns more money on
average than one of us who is a college
graduate that we are only 3% of the Ivy
League college enrollment that we are
less than one of every 30 grad students
in a graduate school that we die younger
and that the morbidity gap between black
and white is in 1992 widening that 56%
of us looking for housing confront and
have to deal with housing discrimination
that's six in 10 of all the newspapers
in the country have no black
professionals on their staff that at MIT
only 14 of 957 faculty members are only
1% or a black that the African male has
joined the Condor and other as an
endangered species but perhaps more
telling than our worsening statistical
profile which was described by both
divita and markers earlier perhaps more
telling than that than those familiar
statistics would be the palpable despair
that has settled over our communities
communities of color not only African
American but Hispanic communities of
color across this country a deep
depression that seems to signal in utter
loss of the ennobling and unifying
spirit of our old movement we witness it
in the disdain for human life manifested
in the fratricide among our young people
the homicide in the violence against
african-american women that is so common
today in the nihilistic self-deprecating
and materialistic cultural expression of
our young people
all matters which will be a subject of
discussion as this conference proceeded
through the next few days where we
should ask is the love of community the
self-love symbolized by our joyful
proclamation that black is beautiful
symbolized by our reach for black power
of 10 and 15 years ago
where is that love of self and of
community and one of the backlash of the
90s surely dr. King would strip away the
new veneer stretched taut over the old
racist shibboleths shibboleths and he
could see the race-baiting demon of the
60s behind the affirmative action quotas
preference debate providing national
politicians with an opportunity to at
the same time distract attention from
the national disgrace that passes for an
economy while scapegoating and pointing
the finger at african-americans as well
dr. King would doubtless see the attack
on multicultural education and
Afrocentric study as an effort to
undermine the campaign to open the
university doors to new thinking and to
new thinkers here I should I can't help
but mention the presidential candidate
Buchanan pulled the veil off of some of
these backlashes and showed their true
stripes when at the beginning of his
campaign he pledged that he would not
stand idly by while Western
judeo-christian culture was thrown into
a quote landfill called multiculturalism
those movement eyes glancing forward to
the black world of the 90s would no
doubt be surprised as well to find deep
ideological fissures among black
activists and thinkers divisions that
are themselves a reflection of the
political disquiet and dissonance
experienced by community that sees
itself left in the dust
of a technological revolution and that
therefore is turning hard new corners in
search of answers answers answers
anywhere dr. King the drum major for
peace would surely be sorrow to hear
America's newest black hero General
Colin Powell claim of his purported
enemy first we're going to cut off their
legs and then we're going to kill them
and what would he say of the cynical
replacement of the civil rights
movements bright light Thurgood Marshall
with Clarence Thomas a man who has
scorned the civil rights leadership and
caricatured them as a bunch of
do-nothing whiners looking for handouts
dr. King went straight to the heart of
the matter in condemning the blight of
poverty he once remarked most of the
poor people in this country are working
every day but earning so little they
cannot begin to function in the
mainstream of the economic life of our
nation they're working on full-time jobs
but for part-time pay and that was in
1965 but could dr. King ever have
imagined that in the United States of
America in 1992 in a cold day in January
corpses would be strewn across the city
streets of homeless people who had the
life literally frozen out of them that
good and decent people you and I our
brothers our sisters our neighbors would
train themselves to step gingerly around
the women and men in tattered rags
averting our eyes pretending not to hear
their mumbled entra teased and never
questioning where those people went when
it was time to go home
what would got the king saying about
that dr. King knew the ku klux kin he
had faced 3,000 Klansmen in Albany in
1962 in st. Augustine Florida in 1963
the Klan had kidnapped the lead
of the local movement and more on the
verge of incinerating them when the
local sheriff intervened in Selma the
Klan openly joined ranks with the state
troopers attacking the marchers on the
pedis
bridge what would dr. King say about his
country 1992 an ex Klansmen running for
president dr. King dr. King had a
particularly keen sensitivity to the
needs and interests of African America
to all of all children but in particular
of his African American children and to
their desire to participate in the
movement in the liberation struggle in
1963 in Birmingham dr. King organized a
march of 6,000 children ranging in age
from 6 to 16 and this entire beautiful
crusade of children from the youngest to
the oldest
were all arrested and carted away in
wagons as they marched and sang we shall
overcome from the 16th Street Baptist
Church into the town people all across
the country country was scandalized and
criticized dr. King for what they called
the use of children but these critics
fell silent when dr. King asked them
where were you with your protective
words went down through the years Negro
infants were born into ghettos taking
their first breath of life in a social
atmosphere where the fresh air of
freedom was crowded out by the stench of
discrimination what would dr. King say
today in 1992 if we told him that just
days ago too little black children in
New York City had their faces painted
with white shoe polish by a group of
white young people who thought it was
funny
blak you three times as likely to be
unemployed as whites 1 million black
young people out of school thousands
more unable to read to write and to
compute what would dr. King say about
the plight of our children today in 1992
what could a young child say looking
back at the movement of 90 in 1960 a
young child with no home with barely a
school to attend what could such a child
say about what that movement had
actually accomplished today is much more
than a birthday celebration but it is
that as well
it's a marking of time with a man who is
a contemporary of ours a celebration of
the life as Marcus's said of a very
young man who began his public life at
the age of 26 26 think of that those of
you who are 19 20 21 and 22 who will
graduate from MIT and go on to other
things
Martin King in Montgomery when he was
called upon to take the leadership of
that movement was 26 from that moment on
he gave us all he had his voice his
dreams his vision of a new world a new
ethic a new peace a new America all that
he had he gave it to us in the 12 years
and four months until he was struck down
we honor dr. King not only for that gift
but for lifting us in our despair now
and then for showing us the way to
greater community and in committing
ourselves to dr. King and honoring him
what we commit ourselves to is action
action in the right times and in what
our enemies might call the wrong times
we pay you the tribute we know you would
treasure most by committing ourselves
for all the years we have left to action
happy birthday dr. king
[Applause]
thank you George Burnham for your
observations for your comments and most
importantly for a very important lesson
in history and for the young folks here
who one thing you take away from this if
nothing else is the fact that don't
necessarily listen to what is written in
the papers go look for yourself for the
foolish story a lot more happens than
we're told about we will now have some
musical selections performing for us
today is someone who is an important
sense an alum of MIT mr. Charles Thomas
was employed here in the in the
admissions office and recently left us
for full-time musical studies at the New
England Conservatory of Music he would
be accompanied today by a prominent jazz
musician in the Greater Boston area mr.
George Russell who leads the George
Russell trio Charles
[Applause]
[Music]
my
please come down
[Music]
[Applause]
I believe that God would start
I don't mind the gray sky
[Music]
calm down
we
everybody know yes he knows our every
cane
[Music]
[Applause]
he'll give peace and comfort
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll tell you Charles you're gonna hurt
yourself doing that well now I'd like to
ask Reverend Brown that she would give
the benediction as we close today's
program bow your heads with me please
Lord we thank you for the dreamer we
thank you for the dream and Lord we're
apologizing because the dream has not
yet become a reality we've not yet
overcome there's much work left to do
there's much unfinished business here in
this nation but we're asking for your
help Lord as we leave this place we go
out with the dream renewed with a newer
understanding of the vision and that
which is required of the responsibility
that we now have having had the vision
explained father make us dreamers make
us workers Lord God let not our thoughts
be idle let not our hands be empty but
put our arms Lord to the task at hand to
bring the vision into a reality and to
stop this dream from becoming a
nightmare Lord we ask your blessing on
the food that we are about to partake
also allow it to give us the strength
necessary Lord to bring the vision into
reality it's a difficult job it's a hard
job but we leave here to God ready to
work as you leave this place but not his
presence remember that only you can make
the dream a reality and his son's name
we pray amen
you